[Musik]
die moderne gesellschaft und die
medizinischen möglichkeiten am ende des
lebens fordern die religiöse sicht auf
den tod und das sterben heraus gibt es
aus religiöser sicht so etwas wie ein
gutes sterben und hilft glaube die angst
vor dem tod zu überwinden
diese fragen diskutieren heute mit drei
gästen aus drei verschiedenen religionen
macoris der buddhismus hält den menschen
an ganz auf den gegenwärtigen augenblick
zu fokussieren bedeutet dass da nun dass
die sich nie mit dem eigenen tod
befassen
doch an befasst sich relativ viel mit
dem eigenen tod aber eigentlich auch in
der vorstellung in der gegenwart also
dass man darüber meditiert dass man die
vergänglichkeit erkennt dass man erkennt
ich bin aus verschiedenen komponenten
zusammengesetzt die sich dauernd wieder
abwechseln
in diesem museum beschäftigt man sich
damit um auch die angst zu verlieren
aber eigentlich dass sein ist immer in
der gegenwart ist das ist schon viel
wichtiger ja bei ihnen isabel not ist es
nicht ein meditieren sondern ein
akademisches in arbeiten zum tod und
befragen des sterbens nie beeinflusst
ihre arbeit ihr persönliches nachdenken
über ihren eigenen tod
die forschung die theologie hilft dabei
menschenbild zu analysieren und zu
schauen was hinter verschiedenen todes
vorstellungen oder todes einstellungen
was führt menschenbildes weltbild
wirksam sind erhältlich im koran wird
oftmals praktisch in einem atemzug der
glaube an gott und der glaube an das
jenseits erwähnt bedeutet das dass man
als muslim automatisch ein engeres
verhältnis zu die jenseitigen leben hat
als sind die seiten auf jeden fall also
glaube an jenseits ist ein sehr
zentrales prinzip glaubens prinzip im
islamischen glauben und wird nach
islamischem glauben der tod
als tor zwischen diesseits und jenseits
gesehen
insofern versteht man den tod eigentlich
als tot in einem kontinuum also das
heißt das leben geht weiter aber in
einen anderen theologischen status
insofern sollte man natürlich auch sich
im leben im diesseits für diesen moment
auch natürlich das leben nach dem tod
sich vorbereiten
wie soll man es tun das konkret aus
indem man die moralische normen im
alltäglichen leben ernst nimmt und auch
dementsprechend behandelt das heisst
dass die menschen nicht verletzt
gutes tut den menschen hilft und so
weiter und so fort was wir aber auch in
anderen religionen das kennen sind diese
aspekte dann zentraler als
beispielsweise rituellen pflichten
religiösen pflichten und diese dieses
moralische richtige handeln lassen sich
voreinander nicht klar trennen im
islamischen glauben deswegen sagt man
dass der islamische glaube und praxis
nicht nur eine orthodoxie beinhalte
sondern eher ein ort wo praxi das heißt
glaubensprinzipien sollen im alltag im
alltäglichen leben in die praxis
umgesetzt werden
jetzt ist oft probiert oft erwähnt dass
der tod in unserer westlichen
gesellschaft das letzte große tabu ist
und nicht wundert es immer das wo doch
die christlichen zentralen glaubens
auffassungen aus leiden tod und
auferstehung bestehen dass der tod so
verdrängt wird wie kann das sein
ihre welt das ist doch irgendwann
widerspruch also es gibt verschiedene
ansichten ob der tod nun verdrängt wird
in unserer gesellschaft die frage ist
was meinen wir mit unserer gesellschaft
was genau verstehen wir unter todt und
dessen tod verdrängen wir wenn wir tot
verträgen
wir können sagen wir haben jeden abend
in den nachrichten tausende tode
verdrängen von daher den tod
man kann ich sagen einfach generell
verdrängen ihn ich denke auch nicht mehr
dass das heute so gültig ist dass wir
den tod einfach verdrängen
wir sehen es in den diskussionen um den
assistierten suizid wie sehen es in den
diskussionen palliativ care das thema
ist auf den tisch sie würden trotzdem
sagen oder ich höre dass er heraus dass
es bestimmte aspekte des verdrängens
gibt ist es dass persönlicher ist es das
was einem persönlich nachging
das ist das was wir verbringen wir
können sagen wir schauen was tut
anbelange verdrängen was was hinter
gesamten sogenannten dritten welt
geschieht tausendfaches millionenfaches
sterben aufgrund zum teil ungerecht
wirtschaftliche verteilungskämpfe
das wird ganz sicher zu einem großen
teil verdrängt aber in unserer wenn wir
jetzt auf unsere gesellschaft
fokussieren uns abkoppeln von diesen
diskussionen das ist ja auch eine der
großen kritikpunkte an diesen ganzen
diskussion dass sie da nicht hinschauen
wenn wir in unseren gesellschaften
schauen zur zeit auch mit dem bericht
des bundesrates zur förderung von
palliativ care 2011 das thema ist
lanciert
also diese enttabuisierung kommt
praktisch auf säkularen oder auf nicht
unbedingt auf religiösem wege wieder
zurück in die gesellschaft verstehe ich
das richtig
in der religion war der tod nie top wie
sieht wir können darüber sprechen welche
traditionen dazu geführt haben dass wir
kein besonders oder sagen zumindest ein
ambivalentes verhältnis zum tod haben
insbesondere im christentum aber der tod
ist sicher kein verdrängtes thema
gewesen
mich interessiert jetzt wie das im
interkulturellen bereich den aussieht
wir haben ja wir sagen gesprächen oft
von bier tabuisieren de toth wir haben
mir ihn auszusprechen oder anzusprechen
wie sieht denn das in diesem türkisch
islamischen kontext aus haben menschen
muslimischen glaubens weniger hemmungen
mit dem tod sich auseinanderzusetzen
darüber zu sprechen in den familien
beispielsweise wir können glaube ich
unterschiedliche umgangsweise im laufe
der zeit innerhalb der muslimischen
kulturkreisen sprechen
in der geschichte war glaube ich der
umgang mit dem tod viel einfacher und
viel selbstverständlicher als wir
derzeit in modernen zeiten haben
als beispiel ist zum beispiel in einer
bestimmten mystischen schule wird der
tod caros also auf basis hochzeitsnacht
genannt das zusammenkommen mit dem
geliebten und wenn sie auch in istanbul
zum beispiel zu diesem historischen
moscheen gehen fast jede moschee hat
einen garten und im garten befindet sich
ein grad fällt das heißt ein
praktizierender muslim der fünfmal zu
moschee geht dann sieht fünfmal am tag
grabfelder das heißt der tod als solche
ist im alltag drin
aber derzeit denke ich mal das jetzt in
der islamischen welt in modernen zeiten
nicht eine angemessene
auseinandersetzung mit tod als solche
gibt ein schönes beispiel ist vielleicht
in bezug auf was sie gesagt haben also
in der türkei zum beispiel ist
palliativmedizin viel schlechter
etabliert was auch in deutschland oder
in der schweiz der fall ist
das heißt palliativmedizin wird
von der gesellschaft nicht akzeptiert
und dann
man hat dann mehr erwartung sozusagen
von hightech medizin weil man tot als
solche nicht akzeptieren möchte
vielleicht nicht zuletzt deswegen weil
medizinischen möglichkeiten viel besser
sind als in der vergangenheit der fall
war
in diesem begriff den sie verwendet
haben also die aussicht auf die
hochzeitsnacht oder die hochzeit als
sinnbild für den tod gibt es so etwas im
buddhistischen denken auch dass der tod
etwas ist das man als und positiven
bildern in verbindung bringt ich glaube
es ist nicht unbedingt positiv oder
negativ gewertet es ist einfach ein
übergang muss ich dieses phänomen das
ich darstelle auflöst weil die
bedingungen für ein weiteres bestehen
nicht mehr gegeben sind und genauso
wenig wie man sich vielleicht aufregt
wenn jemand zur welt kommt und denkt das
ist ganz normal sollte man sich auch
nicht aufregen wenn jemand stirbt
eigentlich weil das ist das einzige was
wir wissen bei der geburt was sicher ist
dass wir irgendwann sterben
ich würde vielleicht gerne zu dieser
diskussion noch etwas beitragen also
diese tabuisierung ich denke das hat
auch viel mit ganz praktischen sachen zu
tun also wir haben jetzt vielleicht er
so auf einer religiösen oder meta ebene
gesprochen aber vielleicht dass wir das
gefühl haben es wird verdrängt und ist
ein tabu hat damit zu tun dass eben
nicht mehr zu hause gestorben wird also
ganz praktisch dass das es wird an
profis weiter vergeben also die pflege
passiert so und das wird kaum zu hause
gestorben also ich habe in japan mit
vielleicht als 28-jährige der 30-jährige
mann zum ersten mal eine tote person
gesehen die dann auch bei uns im haus
noch ein paar nächte aufgebaut wurde und
alle haben den offenen sarg gesehen und
man hat die person noch im krankenhaus
gleich besuch bevor irgendwas passiert
ist und dann hat sich verabschiedet und
gemeinsam denn den sarg getragen und so
weiter die nahen verwandten und so das
ist ja bei uns verloren gegangen an der
totenwache oder was ist alles auch für
bad wo eigentlich auch kleine kinder
schon mitbekommen haben dass die
großeltern sterben dass irgendjemand
stirbt in der familie und ich denke
dieses ganz praktisch ist auch nicht zu
vernachlässigen da können die religionen
noch lange sehr nahe am tod sein und
darüber berichten wenn es im
menschlichen alltag weg ist und man muss
heute jung sein und dynamisch und stark
und cool und so und alles was mit mit
abbau vielleicht mit mit krank werden
mit sterben zu tun hat das wollen wir ja
in der regel nicht sehen eben es ist
verloren gegangen
trotzdem weiß man der große wunsch
bleibt ihm der mehrheits wunsch der
menschen der alten den menschen ist es
zu hause im vertrauten umfeld sterben zu
dürfen
wie geht das nun zusammen also wir haben
den wunsch einerseits aber das faktum
dass ich diesen wunsch eigentlich
mehrheitlich entzieht
es ist eine große diskrepanz zwischen
der zahl von personen die gerne daheim
sterben möchten und der faktizität dass
wir wissen dass es nur circa 25 ganz
grob circa 25 prozent vergönnt ist
daheim gepflegt und dann zu sterben
gepflegt zu werden dann zu sterben und
gian domenico borasio in seinem
berühmten buch über das sterben sagte
die beste altersvorsorge seien getötet
weil großteils die töchter viermal mehr
töchter dann pflegen die eltern als die
söhne
ich möchte gern dass nochmals aufnehmen
was sie gesagt haben die verlagerung des
sterbe ortes ganz klar früher in der
familie im dorf und heute gut 90 prozent
die in dem pflegeheim
in den speziellen sterben aber das
problem ist erkannt und es gibt jetzt
sehr viele diskussionen wie man das mit
mobilen palliativteams zb und
ausgebildeten ärzten in den dörfern
wirklich verändern könnte in den
muslimischen gemeinschaften ich spreche
hier speziell auch die muslimischen
gemeinschaften in der diaspora an
wie ist da die bedürfnislage von
muslimischen patienten und patienten ich
möchte in der praxis zu hause sterben
wollen oder zu hause sterben noch ein
gleich wichtigen punkt nennen nämlich
hat zu hause sterben in der muslimischen
glaubens plugs auch eine moralische
dimension
das heißt man möchte dann am lebensende
sozusagen mit vertrauten personen
zusammenkommen können und auch
gegenseitig verzeihen können weil nach
islamischem glauben wiederum wenn dies
nicht geschieht dann geschieht das ganze
im jenseits
was natürlich ein nachteil für die
verstorbene person sein kann das heißt
es gibt dann auch im moralischen sinne
sozusagen gute argumente fürs zuhause
sterben aber heutzutage ist ja die
rahmenbedingungen ganz anders und vor
allem ich glaube das hat nichts mit der
religion sondern eher mit sozialen
komponenten zu tun dass in einem
bestimmten sozialen klasse
doch vielleicht die erwartung von der
hightech-medizin viel größer ist als
vielleicht in möglichen sozialen klassen
nämlich also man möchte klar jeder
möchte das jetzt ein vater oder mutter
möglichst lang lebt und dann aber dass
man jetzt die diesen wunsch transferiert
man wie sie auch gesagt haben
auf intensivmedizinische
versorgungssysteme was man aber nicht
also sowohl die betroffene person als
familienangehörige ist die situation ein
nachteil weil da kann man dieses zum
beispiel gegenseitiges verzeihen oder
kommunizieren am lebensende und so
weiter und so fort nicht realisieren
und deswegen habe ich auch gesagt dass
die muslime die modernere sich
versorgungssysteme
in diesem kontext noch nicht gut
analysiert haben und die bedeutung diese
möglichkeiten für sich nicht präzisiert
haben das ist glaube ich ein problem und
das muss natürlich noch gemacht werden
sie sind ja auch medizinethiker wie
stellt sich denn die islamische
theologie zu den fragen der leyens
verminderung der lebenserhaltenden oder
verlängernden maßnahmen gibt es da
einheitliche positionen oder oder
verschiedene also genauso wie auch in
anderen monotheistischen oder in anderen
religionen ist das leben auch im islam
heilig und in diesem kontext möchte man
natürlich auch das leben möglichst allen
möglichen mitteln
verlängern nur die frage ist natürlich
ob man jetzt für dieses ziel walisische
maßnahmen anwenden muss wodurch auch ein
leiden entsteht also meine persönliche
meinung dazu ist das jetzt
lebensverlängerung soll nicht um jeden
preis sein
aber er mag sein dass vielleicht in
betroffener personen das nicht möchte
aber die familienangehörigen weil die
möglichkeit als solchen da ist verlangen
das und deswegen es gibt zwar keine
empirische daten also belastbar
empirische daten aber schon sehr viele
erfahrungen dass unser deutschen oder
schweizerischen kollegen uns sagen dass
vor allem bei muslimischen familien
angehörigen der wunsch am lebensende
nach maximal therapie viel häufiger
vorkommt als bei zb christlichen
patienten das leben ist heilig wie
religion
ich würde gern jetzt noch ein werfen wir
stellen uns das leben als gab es als
geschenk und das heißt ein geschenk eine
gabe dass es nicht in dem sinne bis zum
schluss zwanghaft gelebt werden muss
unter der voraussetzung dass große
schmerzen da sind also es gibt da eine
gewisse offenheit ich und ich spreche
jetzt auch seelsorglich dass es
situationen gibt wo man sagen kann
dieses geschenk ist dann ein ende
gekommen
die person die dieses geschenk gehalten
hat hat hier auch legitime oder das ja
es ist legitim zu sagen und möchte ich
gerne das ist schluss ist ist das
legitim also das ist ja für mich
wirklich eine frage ist das theologisch
gesprochen legitim sich selbst den tod
zu wünschen als seelsorgerin es ist ja
nichts anders als sehr verständlich dass
menschen die ganz fest leiden die
wirklich auch sagen ich habe mein leben
gelebt ich bin sagt ich kann wirklich
gehen und ich möchte gehen dass die
person das war
ist aus buddhistischer sicht so ein
wunsch nicht wiederum eine form des
anhaften
also dieses diesen diesen drang zu
verspüren nach etwas zukünftigen was man
für sich wünscht und ich weiß nicht weil
ich je nach person ist vielleicht daran
größer nach nach diesem zukünftigen wenn
eine person an wiedergeburt glaubt das
ist nicht bei allen gleich der fall
und ein anderer klammert sich eben ans
leben aber ich möchte mich da wirklich
anschließen also bei uns geht es immer
darum eigentlich leiden zu vermindern
und es hat ja auch etwas mit
menschenwürde zu tun also wenn ich
einigermaßen natürlich zur welt kommen
darf und ich darf auch selbstbestimmt
leben ist ja dann eine eine verlängerung
die vielleicht manchmal auch nur dem
ehrgeiz der medizin dienen kann im
extremfall kann ja auch zu einer folter
werden und verhindert eigentlich dass
jemand natürlich sterben kann
an seinem ende das jetzt halt gekommen
ist und in dem sinn es macht ihr dann
sicher ein unterschied wähle ich einen
freitod weil ich das gefühl habe
jetzt liege ich nur noch im bett und das
möchte ich nicht und jetzt werde ich
einen freitod oder ich bin an maschinen
gebunden
für internet und und das wird abgestellt
so dass eigentlich der tod er schon
lange eingetreten wäre natürlicherweise
eintreten kann also da würde ich schon
auch noch einen unterschied machen wie
ist der kontext aber wenn es eigentlich
darum geht den natürlichen tod zu
ermöglichen würde ich schon sagen
städten
aber die schwierigkeit scheint ja auch
doch zu sein
die sind zeitpunkt des natürlichen todes
wählen sie immer weniger selbst und er
ist auch offenbar immer weniger klar
sie haben zu beginn gesagt wann ist dann
wenn ich eigentlich tot eigentlich
meinung ist wissen wann er tot ist aber
ist das wissenschafts wirklich so klar
ja also wenn man natürlich über den tod
spricht dann ist natürlich dass
verschiedene positionen dazu aber wenn
das natürlich nicht der fall ist dann
klar kann man natürlich halte als ärzte
den tod feststellen dass es durchaus
möglich nur die frage ist natürlich auch
bis jetzt vor allem die kriterien für
hirntot definition find diagnose auch im
menschenbild des betroffenen als solche
gelten
das ist ja die entscheidende frage und
dazu haben ja die region
unterschiedliche antworten oder auch
innerhalb einer region gibt es
unterschiedliche antworten das muss man
auf gleich sagen ja wir stellen sich
eigentlich die unterschiedlichen
religionen zu fragen der organentnahme
im falle eines todes beispielsweise vom
islam haben wir oftmals zu den eindruck
es gibt so normative ansichten im
christlichen kontext scheint das sehr
viel mehr an pragmatischen fragen sich
auszurichten wie ist da der stand der
diskussion eigentlich nicht
es hängt alle unsere verschiedenen
positionen nicht mehr wir haben wenn sie
wenn sie eine lehramtliche meinung
wurden dann kriegen sie sie hier jetzt
nicht von mir wenn sie die reaktion eine
theologie mit schwerpunkt seelsorge
möchten dann sage ich ihnen bei all
diesen diskussionen ende sehr stark
damit zusammen welches menschenbild
gepflegt wird und welches verständnis
vom tod dahinter steht wenn wir die
würde des menschen das ist ja die ganze
diskussion als beide selbstbestimmung an
seine ode an ihre autonomie knüpfen und
sie da festmachen dann kriegen wir
wirklich schwierigkeiten weil damit
entwürdigen wie
die menschen die nicht mehr so autonom
handeln und sprechen können sei es
aufgrund von altersbedingten kranken
chronischen kranken lebens gefragt sei
es demenz die sind eingeschränkt in
ihrer autonomie
das heißt wir dürfen das
werteverständnis nicht knüpfen an die
autonomie sondern wir müssen fest daran
festhalten die wirte ist unabhängig von
meinem gesundheits oder
krankheitszustand die wirte habe ich als
mensch punkt und das ist jetzt wirklich
die würde des menschen ist unantastbar
das sage ich jetzt als christliche
theologie das sagen aber auch jene die
sich ganz dem end für den freitod den
alters freitod beispielsweise einsetzen
die argumentieren mit dem genau gleichen
begriff also es scheint mir hier auch es
geht um eine einen kampf der
deutungshoheit über den berichten würde
wie ist würde denn im islam definiert
kommt dieser begriff überhaupt vor
man kann ja diese begrifflichkeiten
nicht unabhängig von der jeweiligen
geistes tradition trennen
das heißt wenn wir nicht die kante
philosophie gehabt hätten
in der deutschen geistes tradition dann
hätten wir vielleicht nicht unbedingt
dieselben würde interpretationen in
unseren diskussionen in diesem
zusammenhang haben wir nicht ein
äquivalent menschenwürde begriff
interpretation in islamischen tradition
aber wenn man die islamischen
hauptquellen von diese perspektive
analysiert und dann stellt man doch fest
dass schon ein mensch nur wie sie gesagt
haben weil er mensch ist diese würde hat
und darf deswegen auch dann nicht
instrumentalisiert werden und so weiter
und so fort nur die frage ist natürlich
ob jetzt diese würde der begriff dies
impliziert die jetzt nicht unbedingt im
europäischen kontext denken dass glaube
die entscheidende frage
insofern sehe ich da parallelitäten zu
zum christentum und judentum das zb wie
sie gesagt haben das menschliche leben
gottes gabe ist
wenn man würdig handeln möchte dann soll
zum beispiel also kein selbsttötung in
diesem zusammenhang stattfinden weil der
mensch ist inhaber seines lebens seines
körpers aber nicht besitzer und
gegenüber seinen schöpfer hatte eine
verantwortung und diese verantwortung
platziert nicht selbsttötung und das ist
die interpretation der muslimischen also
dieses gegenüber eines schöpfers eines
gottes der eine bestimmung vor sind für
den menschen
davon geht ja das buddhistische menschen
bin nicht grundsätzlich aus und trotzdem
habe ich keine zustimmung im
buddhistischen kreisen gefunden für den
assistierten suizid wie argumentiert man
aus buddhistischer sicht da muss ich
denke schon es geht darum dass wir nicht
vor dem leben und seinen schwierigkeiten
flüchten und dass wir das leben mit
unseren möglichkeiten halt voll
ausschöpfen bis es irgendwann mal zu
ende geht ich persönlich aber es ist
jetzt meine persönliche meinung würde
auch niemanden verurteilen wollen der
diese entscheidung für sich trifft
also wenn das leben wirklich nur noch
aus schmerz oder vielleicht auch eine
art demütigung besteht weil man selbst
nichts mehr machen kann und wie ein
möbelstück fast von a nach b gebracht
wird und man wird gepflegt und so weiter
und das kann auch sehr andere an der
würde platzen eines menschen und wenn
das mit sehr großen schmerzen verbunden
ist und eigentlich keine perspektiven da
sind und ich aber auf der anderen seite
ein gutes leben gelebt habe und ich weiß
was ich hinterlassen und ich kann gut
loslassen würde ich jetzt einfach
persönlich zeit zurückhaltend sein
jemanden zu verurteilen auch wenn ich
denke es sollte nicht so eine schnelle
lösung seien einfach zu sagen jetzt will
ich nicht mehr
ich denke wir sollten in jeder
lebenssituation auch das positive sehen
können dass ich als bettlägrige patient
vielleicht kann ich nur den mundwinkel
nach oben ziehen und ich
verschönere der krankenschwester oder
der pflege der reinkommt den ganzen tag
weil er merkt was ich tue
macht sinn und dann habe ich einen
menschen freude gemacht für einen tag in
seine arbeit hingegeben und dass das
zeigt auch dass man in jeder situation
noch irgendetwas sinnvolles tun kann ist
sie sind ja auch seelsorgerin waren sie
schon persönlich konfrontiert mit dem
wunsch einer person freiwillig aus dem
leben zu scheiden ja selbstverständlich
ja folgendes sicht immer sehr schwer
über diese thematik zu sprechen weil es
sind ja immer wieder es ist einfach sehr
effektiv geladen
es sind menschen die haben sehr viele
erfahrungen gemacht im familienumfeld
und die haben das zum teil aus als sehr
beeindruckend erlebt aber zum teil auch
sehr schwierig und es ist schwierig
quasi um auch von diesen erfahrungen zu
abstrahieren und zu versuchen zu
analysieren nochmals was für menschen
bilder werden transportiert wenn zb beim
assistierten suizid argumentiert wird es
gehört zu unserer selbstbestimmungsrecht
es ist unsere würde die tangiert wird
zweifeln die an
oder könnte es schwierig ich finde es
schwierig weil nochmals wenn die
selbstbestimmung an das autonome subjekt
geknüpft wird also an die autonomie des
menschen und des individuums dann
schalten wir quasi all jene aus die
nicht autonom handeln können
das heißt menschen mit behinderungen
menschen die die messe dann haben die ja
quasi etwas weniger würde wenn man das
koppelt das sind so die ganz schwierigen
fragen in dieser diskussion
und dann kommt das andere hinzu letztes
jahr hat er das institut für sozial und
präventionsmedizin und der universität
bern eine studie veröffentlicht die mal
die personen analysiert hat die zahlen
analysiert hat die von einem
assistierten suizid gebrauch gemacht
haben und sie sind zum fazit gekommen
erstens mal dass es bedeutende frauen
sind die davon gebrauch machen
und zweitens die vulnerabilität da sind
viel häufiger menschen die alleinstehend
sind oder die oder die geschieden sind
und das heißt wir müssen mal anschauen
was befördert gesellschaftlich einen
trend hin zu assistierten suizid würden
sie sagen was das für faktoren sind eine
entsolidarisierung unsere serie
individualistische gesellschaft auch in
dieser ganzen diskussion wird ja häufig
ausgeblendet mit diesem selbstbestimmung
mit dieser argumentation figuren die
übrigens auch der bundesrat leiter so
verwendet hat mit dem
selbstbestimmungsrecht wie wir leben
nicht nur für uns wir haben familien wir
haben ein umfeld
wir entscheiden nicht nur über uns das
tangiert auch andere aber wir müssen
doch anerkennen dass sich unsere
gesellschaften hin zu einer
individualistischen lebensweise
entwickelt haben können wir das raten
einfach zurückdrehen und sagen aus der
sicht der religionen wie das kollektiv
stärker betont und wir müssen das
selbstbestimmungsrecht reduzieren oder
relativieren meine meine aufgabe ist zu
versuchen darauf hinzuweisen dass wir es
unbedingt reflektieren müssen was wir da
auch ein anderer zumuten wenn das quasi
normativ wird dass die möglichkeit wenn
man sich enthalte jetzt möchte ich nicht
mehr jetzt für mich hat jetzt mein leben
ist jetzt fertig jetzt ein assist
bediene ich mich der möglichkeit eines
assistierten suizid es dann kam das
gesamtgesellschaftlich einen druck
erzeugen auf menschen die das vielleicht
nicht möchten die vielleicht
pflegebedürftig sind und ich weiß nicht
war aber die noch leben möchten
und davor habe ich angst
selbstbestimmung muss man ja auch immer
unter dem blickwinkel betrachten wie
treffen wir entscheidungen also wenn man
sein geist selbst beobachtet und man
schaut
wie das entsteht da bin ich immer in
einen kontext eingebunden in einen
sozialen kontext mit den erfahrungs
kontext eingebunden und wir haben
eigentlich relativ wenig spielraum uns
wirklich intellektuell selbst für
irgendetwas zu entscheiden ganz viele
sachen werden vorher schon unter bewusst
entschieden und da denke ich schon ist
das problematisch
sie sagen eigentlich der
gesellschaftliche druck dass jemand auch
das gefühl hat ja ich falle meinen
angehörigen zu last oder ich falle der
gesellschaft so lustig bin für nichts
mehr gut und natürlich normal dass es
wird dass man dann aus dem leben
scheidet wenn man halt nur noch eine
last ist kann das einen großen druck
erzeugen der dann die sogenannte selbst
bestimmen natürlich irgendwie ja dazu
und umkehrt
frage sie haben mir gesagt das ist jetzt
unsere gesellschaft immer
individualisierter wird und dann ist
natürlich die frage ob man jetzt welche
ethische sage ich mal wertesystem für
dieses leben als wichtiger findet das
glaube ich eine zentrale fragestellung
nämlich also sollen wir jetzt so ein
ethik oder retters meinetwegen wählen
weil jetzt werden die individualisierte
gesellschaft haben
oder sollte man erst eine kritische
auseinandersetzung mit der modernen
lebensweise stattfinden und dann
vielleicht für ethische richtung
entschieden werden also deswegen ist es
glaube ich die türkei ein schönes
beispiel
denn wie wir wissen in modernen
lebensweise brauchen wir sehen
seniorenheime wenn jetzt ja
mal ermahnt und ehefrau arbeitet und
dann muss ja auch diese menschen
gepflegt werden und lange zeit oder in
der türkei
diese institutionen was in europa gebe
es verdrängt da war zum beispiel also
ich darf vielleicht so ein bisschen weil
das amüsante beispiel ist ein beispiel
nennen in einer stadt in der türkei in
anatolien
man hat ein seniorenheim gebaut und dann
sagte der bürgermeister dieser stadt wir
sind stolz darauf wir haben ein
seniorenheim aber wir haben kein
einwohner also ist gemeint eigentlich
das jetzt an ältere menschen zu hause
gepflegt werden uns sofort das natürlich
ideale situation nur wenn natürlich
beide ehepartner berufstätig sind dann
ist es natürlich nicht gut
insofern soll dann halt nicht alles was
jetzt aus dem westen kommt als solche
institution als verwestlichung bzw
kulturelle aus simulation verstanden
werden sondern gucken in welcher
gesellschaft leben mehr mag sein dass
vielleicht die mehrheit der bevölkerung
muslimischen glaubens ist aber wenn die
rahmenbedingungen oder lebensbedingungen
als solche sich verändert haben da muss
man halt gucken welche institutionen für
dieses menschen mit als solche geeignet
sind also wie gesagt nicht auf in bezug
auf lebenssituation ein ethik wählen
sondern erst mal kritisch sich damit
auseinandersetzen
ein sehr schönes beispiel wie sich
kulturelle anschauungen auch miteinander
verweben und eine frage die mich jetzt
dahin führt ist die stellt man sich denn
die frage nach dem assistierten suizid
in der türkei inzwischen auch und die
andere frage
gegen muslime in den westlichen nationen
mit welchen fragen um die sind ja viel
unmittelbare mit diesen fragen
konfrontiert also vielleicht bioethics
glaube ich in diesem zusammenhang die
welt interkulturalität sprechen ein
schönes beispiel
es ist in der bioethik und musik sehr
sehr schwierig mit klassischen
schablonen zu denken das heißt wenn man
jetzt
sagt ein bestimmtes start ist
konservativ und das heißt nicht dass
alle medizinische probleme auf der
gesetzlichen ebene konservativ gelöst
worden ist beispiel iran ist
wahrscheinlich einziges land auf der
welt wo jetzt organhandel unter
bestimmten bedingungen erlaubt ist oder
auch leihmutterschaft sozusagen was in
deutschland verboten ist
das heißt wenn man über iran spricht
dann denkt man sofort ein konservatives
land aber manche dinge sind viele
liberale gelöst
der punkt ist natürlich halt in
muslimischen ländern das vielleicht
nicht unbedingt eine sage ich mal
grundsätzlich auseinandersetzung mit
diesen modernen
behandlungsmöglichkeiten stattgefunden
hat beispiel in vitro fertilisation als
man darüber diskutiert hat dann hat man
gefragt wofür ist das gut
also hilft denn die normalerweise unter
normalen bedingungen keine kinder haben
dann ist muss eigentlich von der muslim
spaß mit ihr erlaubt sein aber man hat
nicht in angemessener form über was ist
jetzt mit so genannten weißen in büren
unserer diskutiert und das ist glaube
ich eine große herausforderung für die
länder dazu gehört meiner meinung nach
muslimischen ländern die moderne technik
auch im medizinischen system nicht
selber produzieren und nicht während der
produktion als soll es solche
auseinandersetzen da muss ich sagen dass
jetzt unserer christlichen kollegen
wirklich im voraus sind und die
auseinandersetzungen diese technik hat
hier schon seit 70er 60er jahren
angefangen und wir haben davon viel zu
lernen was mir auffällt ist es scheint
hier so eine große einigkeit in den
religionen zu geben zu der frage nach
den assistierten suizid ist das jetzt
wirklich dieser große einigkeit und was
ließe sich allenfalls mit dieser
einigkeit machen
im interreligiösen dialog in der
bewältigung dieser fragen in der
gesellschaft also was das finde ich sehr
schön dass uns das ein weil es hat ja
auch zu tun mit dass wir menschen auch
in sozialen gefüge wahrnehmen wir
stellen fest dass wir nicht wie sie
nicht einfach einzelne wir betonen in
den religionen auch unsere sozialität
wir brauchen einander wir benötigen
einander und das ist ja etwas mit in
dieser diskussion dass immer wieder
etwas ausgeblendet wird wir sind
aufeinander angewiesen
und das passt nicht in eine gesellschaft
die leistungsorientiert ist die eben
alles selbst bestimmt orientiert ist
denn in dem moment in dem ich angewiesen
bin auf andere bin ich ja auch ein stück
weit abhängig und wahrzunehmen das wird
auch aus dieser abhängigkeit gar nicht
herauskommen und nicht herauskommen soll
sondern dass unsere freiheit auch darin
begründet dass wir unsere gegenseitigen
abhängigkeiten miteinander gestalten
das wäre wirklich selbstbestimmt und
frei sein
also das anerkennen der abhängigkeit ist
anerkennen des menschen als soziales
wesen jetzt haben wir aber die situation
dass sich unsere gesellschaften in der
in der westlichen welt zumindest immer
religionskritische immer religions-
ferner zeigen wie transportieren wir
denn eigentlich noch diese diese bilder
und diese ansichten aktionen krieg die
schütz ob sie religionskritische sind
darüber müssten wir diskutieren klar ist
die institution krieg ich habe es nicht
gerade die auseinandersetzung mit dem
assistierten suizid die wir eben geführt
haben diese dieses vehement einfordern
des selbstbestimmungsrechtes nicht
verantwortlich fühlen jemandem anderen
gegenüber jedermann einen menschlichen
gegenüber noch einen ich sag jetzt mal
göttlichen gegenüber ist das nicht
gerade ausdruck dieser religions-
distanz es ist frauen ausdruck eines
entschuldigung wenn ich das so deutlich
sagen eines fehlgeleiteten
menschenbildes
wir sind nicht einfach so autonom
niemand und auch die person die das so
sorgen sollen mal wahrnehmen werden
neben ihnen sitzt wäre in ihrem haus
wohnt mit wem sie telefonieren
wer zu den verwandten und freunden und
freundinnen gehört all diese menschen
gehören mit hinein um sie haben
auswirkungen sie brauchen diese menschen
und wenn sie in ein spital gehen sind
sie angewiesen auf die pflege diese
menschen also es ist ein wir sind nicht
monaten und es ist ganz wichtig denke
das ist eines der zentralen aufgaben von
religionen darauf hinzuweisen dass wir
aufeinander angewiesen sind
marco ist sie haben längere zeit in
japan gelebt japan ist ein land das sich
gut mit unseren westlichen nationen
vergleichen lässt
eine ähnlich hohe altersstruktur ähnlich
tiefe geburtenrate
da stellen sich ja wohl die ähnlichen
fragen ja und die stellen sich in japan
denke ich noch viel klarer oder brutale
auch diese individualisierung es ist
zwar ein
gesellschaft die noch viel mehr als hier
auf der gruppe gründet und in dieser
gruppe passiert heute eine extreme
individualisierung genau in den städten
vor allem bloß die frage ist aber was
diskutieren wir hier ist so etwas wie
einen freitod die suizid ist das nicht
einfach ein symptom für etwas und mich
würde eher interessieren weshalb kommt
dass also auch eine individualisierte
gesellschaft kann eine soziale
gesellschaft sein wir sind das nur nicht
gewohnt also das ist etwas im wandel und
wir müssen vielleicht lernen damit
umzugehen dass wir haben jetzt erklären
wie sie mich ist das klingt das nach
widerspruch ja im ersten blick
vielleicht aber ein soziales gefüge war
bis jetzt vor allem die familie in
irgendwelchen gruppen die irgendwo im
dschungel leben war das vielleicht eher
eine ganze gruppe wo wo man sich
ausgeholfen hat verdi zu den kindern
schaut und so weiter wir gehen jetzt in
eine andere richtung eine
individualisierte richtung wir haben
auch neue medien und so weiter wir
können mit denen vielleicht noch nicht
umgehen
für mich ist es nicht unbedingt ein
widerspruch wir können vielleicht mit
der situation noch nicht umgehen und
sollte neben vielleicht uns überlegen ja
wieso kommen leute zu so einem schluss
oder wieso haben wir so eine beziehung
zum tod was ist in dieser gesellschaft
falsch oder was bräuchte es für neue
formen in der gesellschaft dass wir uns
trotzdem wie früher im dorf in der
familie auch wieder aufgehoben fühlen
und religion haben halt vielleicht
manchmal mühe auch schritt zu halten
auf der anderen seite denke ich
religionen könnten eben auch die impuls
ergeben wie kann man auch in einer
veränderten gesellschaft und vorwärts
gerichtet veränderungen machen
[Musik]
die aber nicht ein ethisches - bedeuten
für mich stellt sich jetzt die frage
wenn wir nach dem gründen vielleicht
noch einmal fragen wie was sind die
gründe dass sich heute vermehrt menschen
bei sterbe organisationen melden
was haben die erkenntnisse darüber warum
warum ist dieser wunsch da sozusagen
unter kontrolle dass selbst kontrolliert
aus dem leben zu scheiden sind
verschiedene gründe ich ich würde mal
einen ganz grundlegenden sagen es ist
auch eine implizite kritik an der
heutigen hochtechnisierten medizin
es ist die angst auf die ausgeliefert zu
sein es ist die angst dass da ein
ärztlicher paternalismus dass da etwas
mit mir gemacht wird gegen meinen willen
und ich kann mich gar nicht mehr werden
das ist ein ganz zentrale und uns gut
nachvollziehbare angst dann aber
eigentlich für mich der das
gegenbeispiel zu dem was sicherlich
vorhin gesagt haben diese große
zuwendung in muslimischen kreisen zu der
hightech-medizin wie gesagt ich habe ja
auch schon genannt das in der
islamischen welt keine dezidierte und
auch grundsätzlich auseinandersetzung
mit mit der bedeutung der modernen
medizin stattgefunden hat also
einerseits das wäre ja immer halt
importieren moderne medizin in die
muslimische länder aber wir haben nicht
zeitgleich die kultur oder die
auseinandersetzung skulptur mit der
modernen technik entwickelt das ist das
problem und sehr viel stelle ich fest
dass die beiden das wissen als solche
wenig ist oder nicht ausreichend ist ist
die erwartung auch dementsprechend von
der high tech medizin und davon der
europäischen medizin sozusagen so hoch
und nach dem motor die können mein vater
oder mutter retten weil das wissen als
solche fehlt
und sie haben ja den begriff
paternalismus benutzt und ich kann nur
bestätigen und meinen jetzigen
erfahrungen in istanbul ist es so dass
jetzt diese paternalistische
handlungsweise der ärzte viel häufiger
und intensiver sind als in deutschland
und in der schweiz der fall ist insofern
wenn man natürlich nicht dem entsprechen
angemessen diese menschen informiert und
wenn diese dinge dann ist natürlich die
erwartungen hoch und vielleicht vor
allem ich hab das auch betont kam mir
der wunsch nach maximaler therapie
obwohl die ärzte eine therapie
begrenzung und therapie abbruch
empfehlen nach maximale therapien das
ist das problem
und vor allem in muslimischen ländern wo
vielleicht die finanziellen ressourcen
nicht so groß sind wie in der schweiz
geht es um nicht nur lions linderung
versus lebensverlängerung sondern auch
geht es um allokation fragen das heißt
gerechte verteilung der ressourcen also
wir haben zum beispiel so einen fall
gehabt in der türkei da war ein
autounfall junge mann und braucht
unbedingt einen intensiv bett aber da
ein 30 80 oder 85 jährige auf diesen
intensiv bett war und die haben gesagt
wir haben keine betten und musste diese
junge mann transportiert werden und auf
dem weg starb er
das heißt das soll dann zwar gibt es
auch solche fragen auch hier aber dort
viel häufiger und deswegen muss diese
auseinandersetzung und wir sollen dann
auch halt unser mediziner so ausbilden
dass auf der mikroebene diese
gerechtigkeitsfragen in angemessener
form beantwortet aber auch entschieden
werden ansonsten können wir wie bei
diesem fallbeispiel zb diese menschen
verlieren und die ressourcen nicht
effektiv anwenden
das führt mich ein bisschen zu der frage
welche wie verändert sich eigentlich die
rolle der ärztinnen und ärzte bei dieser
ganzen frage nach dem sterben
übernehmen sie heute vermehrt sind die
entscheidungsinstanz wann ist ein leben
noch würdig waren ist das nicht mehr
würdig welche rolle haben im gegensatz
dazu eigentlich gesehen sorgen
seelsorge also jetzt als buddhistischer
sicht möchte ich dass das das wort dem
loslassen nicht anhaften
ja das hat ziemlich viel damit zu tun
also kann der mensch der im sterben ist
selbst loslassen kann er sterben können
die verwandten loslassen können die
ärzte loslassen und wir haben jetzt zeit
einmal die menschheitsgeschichte
anschauen eine sehr kurze zeitspanne wo
wir technische möglichkeiten haben die
uns früher nicht gegeben worden und wird
sind wie kinder mit einem neuen
spielzeugen können noch nicht richtig
damit umgehen und diese dieses
versprechen praktisch ich kann das leben
seines vaters vielleicht retten was
immer das dann bedeuten soll spricht
natürlich seine nur wunsch in uns an der
früher gar nicht zur debatte stand weil
so der einfach gestorben und heute hat
man klickt man seine hoffnung so
hingestreut und man hat wieder etwas
mehr kann man sich klammern kann und
jetzt als buddhistischer sicht würde ich
sagen ja
es wäre eben wichtig jetzt aus buddhist
zum beispiel eben schon das ganze leben
sich mit anhaftungen auseinanderzusetzen
loslassen zum thema zu machen damit ich
nicht nur an eine eine maximierung in
einer zeitspanne denken sondern
vielleicht eine maximierung von qualität
und das eben im wandel ein aus im wandel
ist es auch normal ist loszulassen und
das auch eine qualität sein kann eben
jemand den man betreut sei es sehr wand
würde jemand etwas sehr sorge dass man
hilft loszulassen und wir haben
vielleicht noch von früher eher das bild
wir müssen die person helfen möglichst
lange am leben zu bleiben ich denke
heute also wenn ich mit anderen personen
die viel mehr erfahrung haben also ich
in diesem gebiet spreche
dieses nicht loslassen können
oder dass leute erst in den nacht
sterben nachdem die verwandten heim
gegangen sind weil sie nicht damit
umgehen konnten und die ep verwandten
haben sie nicht losgelassen
als auch diese natürliche umgang dass es
einmal ein ende hat und wir uns da nicht
von technik eigentlich ein versprechen
geben lassen dass die technik auch nicht
halten kann so vielleicht dazu also ich
hab ja in deutschland mediziner
ausgebildet und jetzt will ich in der
türkei mediziner aus natürlichen mit
ethischen fragen in diesem zusammenhang
sollte man vielleicht sagen dass wir
unseren jungen mediziner mit
synchronisierten enden nicht nur lebens
wetten oder lebens verlängern sondern
genauso sterben lassen oder erlauben
jemand zu sterben auch lehren müssen
das dachte ich vielleicht beispiel
konkreter machen als ich das pc spiel
absolviert habe war auch ein kommilitone
von mir und war provinz arzt und hat nur
lebens retten in seinem mit sie
schwimmen gelernt und dann bei 1 85
jeden mann war wirklich sterbeprozess
und vielleicht letzte atemzug und
angefangen zu lernen und in die
situation hat man auf seine schulter
geklopft also die ablation gegangen dann
hat man gesagt herr doktor bitte
erlauben sie unseren vater zu sterben
wir sollen dann auch nicht nur
lebensmittel sondern auch sterben lassen
lehrern unseren jungen mediziner und in
ihre frage sehe ich auch diese message
dass wir eigentlich vor allem bei jungen
medizinern sterben eines patienten als
versagen eines arztes verstanden wird
und das müssen wir glaube ich eine
ausbildung und fortbildung in den
ansonsten ist es sehr sehr schwierig das
erleben sie wie in der spitalversorgung
der ausbildung als da kommt jetzt ganz
viele zusammen es hängt mit unseren
todes bilden zusammen
werden jetzt ganz stark über lange zeit
sehr negativ aus so ziert der tod wie
kann es auch aus der bibel mitdenken ist
der tod als feinde tot aus der sünde
sollt es ist quasi die quittung die man
kriegt für die sünde also sowohl das
überhaupt eingeführt und wenn man diese
tradition anschaut ursprünglich also
dass der tod ursprünglich also etwas
ganz natürliches zum leben gehört und in
der vorstellung dass die sünde aufgrund
der sünde der tod in die welt eingeführt
wurde dass der mensch das quasi selbst
verschuldet hat und aus der tod etwas
ist das ursprünglich gar nicht zu ihm
gehört das sind diese bilder die wirksam
wurden und deshalb galt es den tod als
todfeind des menschen eben zu überwinden
unterart hat sich den verschieden noch
zum anderen wenn sie sagen wer bestimmt
bestimmte art dabei leben jetzt noch
nötig ist zu legen oder nicht es mir
nochmals ganz ganz wichtig ein leben hat
wird völlig unabhängig davon ob ich noch
meine geistige fähigkeiten zusammen habe
ob ich noch selber auf die toilette
gehen kann ob ich meine schuhe sehr gut
ich habe heute punkt es ist nicht
gekoppelt an meinen zustand die würde
eines menschen die geld gut so viel
macht das führt mich über zu einer
nächsten frage nämlich bisher war es ja
vor allem die religion und war die
christliche religion die christlichen
kirchen die deutungshoheit hatten über
den begriff der würde und über das
moralisch richtig und falsch jetzt in
einer multireligiösen multikulturellen
gesellschaft aber eben auch in einer
gesellschaft die immer mehr menschen
entfernt von von religiösen fragen ist
ja auch diese deutungshoheit in frage
gestellt wir gehen christliche kirchen
denn mit diesem umstand
ich habe dann ein so gut
in dem sind das natürlich das ist ja
auch das spannende am interkulturellen
interreligiösen dialog wir haben ja die
heftigsten diskussionen ja nicht jetzt
bremen mit anderen religionen sondern in
den christlichen kirchen selber das muss
man jetzt auch hier deutlich sagen aber
das ist ja auch herausfordernd das
belebte auch die diskussion und es
stellt in frage und wenn wir davon
ausgehen dass menschen die sich auf
einem religiösen spirituellen weg
befinden ja auch lernen wollen dann ist
das ja nichts was gut
es ist aber doch so dass die seelsorge
gerade auch die spital seelsorge
beispielsweise ja immer noch sozusagen
exklusiv in den kirchlichen
institutionen verankert ist aber wir
haben ja schon ganz lange nicht mehr die
situation dass der großteil der
patienten einfach ganz
selbstverständlich sich als christinnen
und christen bezeichnen was heißt das
für die seelsorge gerade am ende des
lebens selbstverständlich ist es zeit
und das alte dorf holland deutschland in
den usa selbstverständlich sind die
special teams will sie dort vor allem
heißen sind die eine weltanschaulich
pluralen und einer interreligiösen
gesellschaft angepasst
das heißt die dominanz die wir in der
schweiz noch haben dieses monopol der
täglich christlichen sehr beliebt ist
historisch gewachsen
aber die ist natürlich tragen sich auch
zu verändern im wandel denkt daraus
genau zum seelsorger begriff gibt es ja
auch in verschiedenen monotheistischen
religionen unterschiedliche tradition
der erfahrungen
wenn wir jetzt islamische praxis als
solche gucken ist ja nicht in derselben
form institutionalisiert und
professionalisiert aber die bedürfnisse
vor allem in einem modernen gesellschaft
sind da und deswegen gibt es auch die
nachfrage bei muslimischen patienten
nach muslimische seelsorger
die frage ist natürlich wie man das
gestaltet und neben diese nachfrage oder
bedarf ist auch eine andere funktion
eines muslimischen theologen in
medizinischen fragen
da nämlich wenn jetzt ein muslim sich in
einer bestimmten situation theologisch
überfordert fühlt dann kann er ein immer
fragen bzw eine mufti und die heißt ein
muslimischer theologen der dafür
speziell ausgebildet ist und wir haben
als ich in deutschland tätig war war ich
auch mitglied des kinns ethikkomitees
und da haben wir solche beispiele gehabt
wo jetzt bevor ein patient eine
entscheidung trifft wollte mit einem
imam darüber sprechen und dann seine
entscheidung treffen das glaube ich eine
andere sozusagen anwendungsform als was
wir im christentum sehen in solche
situation denke ich als medizinethiker
das eigentlich wenn jetzt der wunsch von
patienten als solcher kommt danach
dann ist das okay also das ist jetzt für
mich dann keine beeinträchtigung der
patientenautonomie wenn man so will aber
darf nicht auf jeden fall von außen
gezwungen werden das glaube ich sehr
sehr wichtiger punkt und viele patienten
waren dann nach diesem namen gesprächen
sozusagen erleichtert und auch haben
sich wohlgefühlt und natürlich ihre
individuelle entscheidung getroffen
vielleicht noch zum schluss bei diesen
ganzen ethischen fragen des lebens und
des sterbens und der tatsache dass eben
nicht mehr exklusiv in den christlichen
kirchlichen kreisen angesiedelt sind
wie bringen sich den anderen
religionsgemeinschaften zumindest jetzt
mal in der schweiz
zu diesen fragen ein gibt es formen der
institutionellen mitgestaltung
deshalb denke ich auch viel zu tun mit
den ressourcen die die einzelnen
gruppierungen haben die sind eben nicht
überall gleich professionalisiert jetzt
bei den christlichen kirchen ich denke
es ist gerade auch von von
krankenhäusern immer eine größere
offenheit in diesem thema der fall jetzt
in bern das inselspital
das hat ein kernteam das aus theologen
und theologinnen besteht aber die haben
eine liste mit leuten die sie zu ziehen
können aus praktisch allen religionen
die eigentlich vollkommen und man trifft
sich da auf spanisch und die die
er hat die bereitschaft hat dazu zu
lernen oder abzugeben denke ich ist groß
also das ist auch ein wandel und ich
habe mir sagen lassen dass eben gerade
auch durch diese veränderung sind die
die die pflegenden sehr offen für die
seelsorge wieder geworden also man nicht
auf der rieder wollen wir den seelsorger
begriff noch beibehalten denn nicht weil
wir das irgendwie an das moderne nennen
aber die dienstleistung als solches wird
sehr gerne in anspruch genommen habe ich
mir sagen lassen und das ist eine große
bereitschaft da auch weil eben heute an
den meisten orten man wirklich auf den
wunsch patienten eingeht also die müssen
eigentlich wollen das jetzt ein
seelsorger kommt und und nicht mehr
vielleicht wie vor jahren das klappt
einfach plötzlich unter städte pfarrer
und man denkt oh ich bin ich jetzt am
sterben
was will der hier also da wird auch
denke ich immer vorsichtiger mit den
patienten umgegangen und habe die
interreligiöse seelsorge sehr genau
gekommen
wir machen regelmäßig islamische
seelsorge tagungen also wir haben einen
intensiven kontakt also wir sehen es tut
sich sehr viele aus dem bereich in
unserer gesellschaft das ist alles
andere als still stand es ist sie würden
wahrscheinlich mir zustimmen stetige
veränderung und stetiger wandel
ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich für
dieses gespräch bei ihnen an
existenzielle fragen stellen sich nicht
nur am lebensende sondern immer häufiger
auch zum lebens beginnen
wie gehen wir mit den medizinischen
möglichkeiten bei der zeugung der geburt
und bei frühgeborenen um darüber
unterhält sich in einer woche mein
kollege norbert bischoff berger mit
seinen gästen
[Musik]